hello everybody and welcome to the
corridor cast where we have a great
episode for you today
Clint Jake and myself are sitting down
for a crew cast here where we're going
to talk about our experiences growing up
and how that affects the children that
we now have we're also going to talk
about futuristic junk like cybernetic
implants and all that kind of fun things
also Clint has come to us today to share
a very very harrowing story of a
near-fatal experience he had on a set
once and it definitely requires listener
discretion so we will give you a little
heads-up right before we begin that
story but I would highly recommend
sticking around to listen to it because
I think everyone learned a lot and
hopefully you will too after listening
to it we have come from a Jones here on
the podcast that's only for the
government that's what the government
knows you by know I know you by that
name now yeah the government sent me
they tried to get me in the draft they
tried it tried you put kuntum a Jones I
didn't put that the government sent me a
letter to who dressed a kuntum a Jones
like this that's like the worst thing
you could possibly send me I'm not gonna
I'm not signing up for the draft your
draft letter was addressed to kuntum a
Jones yes it was I just love how there's
a verbal system of communication when it
comes to high levels of government cuz I
I kid you not
III think it's at one point the IRS sent
me a letter addressed to Samuel a source
a sor SEI source e source a so I must
have said Gorski and they're like source
a source a so I say source a what was
that did you ever did you return to
sender no every once in a while I it's
it's it's like it's some weird sub
office or something I forget what it was
but hey I still get these letters yearly
I don't know what it is have you ever
gotten a second contemn a Jones letter I
have never gotten a second kuntum a
Jones letter but
if I did I would probably frame it and
then the following layers I would just
she sent to the paper shredder well is
it because you had like one of those
things where you have to fill in each
box with capital letters and you were
unclearly right you like someone tricked
you in high schools like hey so on this
form and you're like okay like the L and
I were probably a little too close
together yeah so it was like like see
you yeah that's funny
some like shady recruiter and your high
schools like hey well I actually signed
up for the Marines I what there you go
well okay so it was like it was the
Marines form I wanted to be in the
Marines so bad since I was little cows
like running around the neighborhood
with my freaking toy gun yeah
sneaking up on the on the front entrance
and like watching the cars come in with
my binoculars to be a horror story about
that oh yeah and like that was my life
as a kid right and I would build like
forts out of camo netting with night
we'd wake up at 6:00 in the morning I
build forts and whatnot and great after
high school I was like yeah yeah let's
do it
Marines let's go I was ready and and
then I realized nah I just want to do
video stuff and like make films and tell
stories and do the whole crazy thing
that oh you could you could take
pictures for us
in the military I was like really that
what that was a conversation that
happened yes yeah so slowly so a
recruiter or wow this yeah is this a cup
here how did this happen oh I'd already
signed up at this point I had not signed
a bed call them and like guys yes okay
do this and so we brought you in or
something like that how did that go
after that um yeah it was all it was all
through the phone and he sent me papers
went through and it was awhile ago
someone might I don't know exactly what
happened but I just remember I was
talking to a recruiter for a few weeks
and he kept calling me and he kept
calling me and then like I slowly
started realizing I'm probably good on
this you know I'd rather just do film
and and this is fun and this is my I'm
this is where life is taking me right
now and um and I stopped I stopped
picking up the phone and he just left me
he's angry voice mails these angry voice
messages and he started to intimidate me
I got scared from like what you started
made me feel basic oh oh oh okay alright
you're not gonna sign up I see how it is
you make me waste my time you waste my
time for this like
do you want this or not okay and I was
like yo dude voicemails he was saying
this I would pick up and you'd be like
dude why did you not pick up the phone
I'm like whoa I was getting hassled by
this recruiter and I'm like I'm good man
so I eventually I just blocked his
number I told no and then he kept
calling and kept calling I was like I'm
just I'm done with this guy
so that's fascinating maybe he was the
the guy who sent me the letter I don't
know maybe I mean like but it he
submitted paperwork that said yeah it's
fascinating I mean I feel like it's it's
kind of like it's it's the it's the
games it's the movies it's the TV stuff
it's all all all that stuff you know you
get wrapped up in the culture is that a
friend like that in college to who we
played tons of Call of Duty for together
you know and he was studying to get like
a medical degree and at the end of his
undergraduate program he you kind of
turned everyone he's like guys I think
I've changed my mind I'm gonna become a
sniper really and he's like yeah and
then like but like this is over the last
few months before we graduate he starts
ordering like these airsoft revolvers
and stuff and I'm like dude this is like
you play portal glasses for $19.99 on
the mercial he didn't he did it
basically this just went on until he
graduated and then uh yeah he basically
spoke with his parents and they're like
are you are you serious are you kidding
me
you become a sniper in the Marines or
something a Navy SEAL and then basically
they set him straight and he finished
his medical degree and he was gonna give
up a medical degree for that yeah Wow
the funniest part is you can't choose
what you're gonna do in the military
like you take a test and as far as I as
far as I understand you take a test and
then they pick a place you where they
need catch like I'm like I'm gonna be a
sniper
it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna make the
funny videos before presentations that's
like that's what you would have done
yeah all right so we're gonna attack
this base but first yeah we have a video
presentation by come to me the more you
prove yourself the more
ability you have to choose but yes
generally you're right yeah did you ever
consider that Jake oh yeah oh yeah when
I was growing up oh for sure my brother
had a t-shirt that was olive drab green
and it had a marine on it that looked
like [ __ ] Popeye and had said like a
guy with a gun no yeah he was like dark
you know he was like a you know devil
dog and he and the shirt said feelin
mean like a u.s. Marine and we used to
put that shirt on and we used to go to
army surplus and by the woodland camo
and we used to have face paint we had
face paint designs we used to do this
Sam we were surrounding this development
out in the country and each each lot had
its own like two acres and so your your
neighbor's house you can see your
neighbor's house but it's like way over
there mm-hmm so me and my brothers and a
couple of our neighbors there was like
there was like a squad of like six of us
and we used to get all dressed up in
full camo with fake with fake rifles
would he do this wooden rifle we used to
go sneak behind our neighbors houses and
climb up into trees and with booth
binoculars spy op yes just spy on people
that was what we did we used to just go
around the neighborhood and spy on
people and you won one night it was it
was it was the late summer and it was it
was dusk and we decided that it was
gonna be a good idea to instead of doing
a rear approach for reconnaissance that
night we were gonna do a frontal
approach Palsy yeah and so the back of
these lots was surrounded by trees it
was like a little clear ring in a field
where all the houses were built and
there was surrounded by trees see from
the back you were good but from the
front you had to creep through the
through the grass there was very little
coverage and so we're sneaking up one
night we're crawling in our and there's
like five of us and we're crawling in
woodland camo like little 10 year olds
no he's post up behind these trees and
we start spying on our neighbors and
they're having dinner or whatever I
don't know and all of a sudden the dad
like looks through the window and
[Laughter]
get down we all get super low and freeze
that he opens up the door under the
stoop and he stands there and he just
puts his arms like this he goes what the
hell are you doing no one says a word it
just stands there good I'm gonna ask you
one more time what the hell are you
doing and my brother perks up me goes
spying because not on my property or not
maybe I'll get up and just sprint away
little squad yep so yeah needless to say
you know that was definitely something
that was on my radar but I got offered a
track scholarship to go to the
University of Notre Dame so you know I
took that yes yeah yeah almost made it
into the army though oh yeah I mean half
man one more step in you've been shipped
off yeah one time I almost fell out of a
tree man mm-hmm we built forts all over
the woods I know yeah yeah that's
interesting you uh I mean it's it's
weird like do you think you'll let your
kids put on the camouflage and face pain
go sneaking around yeah I mean as long
as it's you know as long as I could
consider it safe and I'd know like
generally where they are and who they're
with and you know you kind of have to
gauge that as a parent like based upon
your kids development and age yeah it's
weird because you know now is it like as
a new parent as well it's like you think
about things that you did that gave you
good experiences and obviously you want
the same for your children but you know
sometimes it's like I wonder if
sometimes you think about those
experiences and it's more like a
nostalgia thing and maybe there were
things that you could have improved
about it you know you know or like is
there a way to maybe look through that
uh those experiences with the the lens
of the present day so to speak you know
because in middle school high school
running around with like airsoft guns
like in public parks having airsoft
price it's like not the most appropriate
thing these days but it was
blast right yeah I'd wish my guess the
same I mean parenting is weird like that
in the sense that it gives you a choice
of how you want to present information
to your kids
mm-hm and you can choose to present
information the same way it was
presented to you or not but yeah well
for example the other day wendy was at a
garage sale and she found this little
log with a pistol and like little
plastic bottles where it's like a laser
and when you shoot it at the log like
there's a little thing that pops up and
it knocks the bottles off and it's just
like a little thing mm-hmm
you know and then I have all these I
have all these toys from when I was
younger like a little nine millimeter
squirt gun yeah and Eliza's playing with
them and you know you're thinking oh
okay she doesn't know what that is like
yeah you know she's is it is that fine
and you kind of have to judge it
contextually you know I don't think
there's like a I think I know some
parents are very anti and they're like
no guns no army no any of that mm and I
don't know I don't know if I don't know
if necessarily just drawing bright-line
rules on stuff like that is the best
policy to approach any topic with mm-hmm
yeah it's like cuz it's the same thing
it's it's it's a weird it's a weird
habit to get into it's like a kid puts a
night helmet on it's like you are not
joining the order son yeah like yeah
right they slaughter and Massacre yeah
it's also you know this this side of our
culture goes act like thousands and
thousands of years to you know like that
the the Hara Hara wise how do you say
that day basically turning soldiers into
heroes yeah heroism
yeah heroism yahwism so you know that's
been around forever obviously things
changed a little bit through like World
War one and World War two when Wars got
deadlier and and now with modern-day
with you know people opening up on
people in public and stuff like that but
I don't know I feel like there's still a
there's still a place for for fun games
like that and
and for a little bit of yeah yeah it
teaches you kind of you know you're out
you're out there with your friends and
you're out playing playing war and you
fall or you stumble or you get hurt or
whatever teaches you a little bit about
yourself so I think that part of its
important mm-hmm
certainly I mean I feel like uh there's
a there's a topic that's floating around
and uh also in the Joe Rogan podcast you
know it's really relevant but he had a
guest talking about how kids kind of are
lacking that free range ability these
days we have how protective a lot of
parents can be but also how I guess I
don't wanna say judgmental but it's
almost like a stigma of like even on
parents what they assume a good parent
should be like so that when you see a
child that is out alone you know there's
that instinct to call the cops or CPS or
something because clearly something's
wrong if a child is left unattended
somewhere even in a park
which is not inherently wrong in a lot
of neighborhoods most neighborhoods I
argue I think it depends on the park and
the age of the kid and what the kid
looks like at the time do they look
distressed do they look like they've
been out there do they look you know
what kind of clothes do they have on
like what's their face look like what
are their emotions where is the park
does it look like there's other people
in the park where there's a picnic and
there's a kid close by yeah is it in a
neighborhood is it in an industrial
district you know there's all these sort
of contextual things that I think you
need to take into account when it comes
to things like that yeah what kind of a
random question actually Clinton what
kind of rules do your parents have for
you when you were growing up hmm I was I
was raised in a Christian household we
went to church every single Sunday and
there was its rules um my dad was really
really cool
my dad is the one who got me into music
he was a drummer he was in a band when
he you know when he was my age
um my dad was the one who got me into
like the matrix and Braveheart and all
those sweet move like all the movies and
he was the one who like let me watch him
play Vice City
I couldn't play it but I could watch and
play it and then eventually I could play
it it's like you know he was ICT a yeah
yeah yeah we'd only get to two stars on
the cops and then he'd sometimes agree
the paint job yeah yeah yeah so it's
like he was he was super chill and you
know like I got spanked as a kid I would
get the belt or I get the pinch with the
twist you know but like the purple
nurples are we talking anywhere did my
mom would like for again like pinched my
arm and it's a pinch and twist twist I
never got a pen somewhere
mom technique but yeah I get it grandma
tech and that moment where my dad
pinched he would just he would just get
the tiniest little pieces but like um
rules man no nudity anytime like you
couldn't take your clothes off I
couldn't take no no no like like like if
there's a if there's a like a sex scene
in a movie I've got to close my eyes if
there were nips you know I'd have to
close my eyes you know that kind of
stuff as long as I don't cuss I can
continue watching movies and games were
with cussing in it you know I was I was
that kid outside running around with
airsoft guns in the hills you know
getting ya chased by rattlesnakes and
the camo children camo children yeah
crawling through the sewer pipes and the
drains and like I was that was okay
going going back to the the topic of
kids right I would love to have kids one
day I think that's gonna be awesome
I think it'd be really cool so how how
do you how do you decide when a man and
a woman love each other no but like how
are you guys like to your point Jacob
like you can you can introduce them to
something the way you were introduced to
it or not yeah like how are you deciding
if that's if that's the what like cuz I
could easily overthink it you know where
it's like uh I don't know I don't know
if they should you know be out running
around I think
the thing that I fall back on is well a
make sure it's balanced right whatever
their interaction is with almost
anything I mean Wendy and I had this
conversation about Disney the other
night where she take her to Disneyland
we watched Disney movies but then the
subject came up of whether or not she
could do her hair and dress up like a
princess and I had that for me I need to
draw the line there really think yeah
because I think there's a there's a
distinction
well that so that's my first part I'll
get to that in a second and then the
second part is understand so everything
is moderation and then also understand
that your kids are gonna be their own
people mm-hmm and you can't always
control what they think do and say and
act and eventually they'll become their
own people whether you want them to or
not so you have to be comfortable with
just giving them the information and
then eventually letting them decide so
why draw the line with it so we caught
this one about Halloween oh and also
yeah like how and how is that different
from dressing up in camouflage and being
a camo child Yeah right you know that's
a great question Sam I didn't think of
that but I'll give you my answer for
Disney and I'll give you my logic so
Disney movies are great right they have
a lot of motivational characters they
have inspirational characters of all
different types of all different
backgrounds but the thing that I think
they fail to do a lot of the time is
present truth in 99% of situations
because those don't make good stories if
somebody take frozen for example she
goes out to find her sister Anna
Princess Anna goes out to find her
sister and she's with the other guy
right and they're looking around for her
and eventually you know they find her
she kicks him out and then she basically
at the end she's sick and she's gonna
die and she needs like a kiss to save
her and then they meet on the lake and
it's like they get the kiss and then
it's okay but in 99% of situations you
just be dead in that scenario you know
if like there was some witch with like
ice powers and
struck you with a lot with a nice bolt
and it froze your heart you just died
but that doesn't make for a good story
you know so there needs to be some sort
of like deus ex machina intervention
that that somehow gives you this closure
or this wrapping up of a situation that
was previously dangerous and deadly or
incorrect
yeah and incorrect behavior although not
to get too far in the weeds but you know
when you are dealing with a world where
there's ice witches shooting bolts you
know I feel like well not about
dissecting my and take word has to hit
for it to do that take Moana is another
in each in each Disney scenario and each
in each Disney story there's always a
person that saves the day by and large
you know there might be a few outliers a
few exceptions here and there but
there's always somebody that comes in
and saves the day despite all odds so
and that's not real life are you worried
that Eliza is going I be worried that if
we dress her up and we like Tiger to
Disneyland and then all of a sudden she
starts to like think I am one of these
characters my life is really like this
and then when they get older and they
realize real life isn't like that they
start to attach to that as the only
thing in their life okay that had any
sort of comfort and like happiness I
rather than just confronting the world
for what it is and being like look 99%
of the time this is what's gonna happen
don't forget about the one percent
because the one percent is the thing
that actually like tells a great story
or in society like actually makes
progress but 99% of the time this is the
truth okay and and I don't think that
Disney ever really acknowledges that I
just think you go a little too far down
the road you might start thinking that
okay and I I think I I largely agree and
I mean but once again you're clarifying
like we're talking about like dressing
up not during a costume occasion right
Halloween yeah I'm talking about
dressing up on Monday yeah like Monday
yeah Wendy and her mom and and Eliza all
go to Disneyland right say it's like a
random day right and they're like
Tuesday we're gonna go to Disneyland
because they have annual passes yeah and
it's like now the kids dressing up every
Monday to go to Disneyland it's like I
see where is the
in between that in real life I I totally
understand I think for me that's where
it was and I think that definitely plays
into having unrealistic relationship
expectations yes that when when you
become older because you get very
engrained in a fictional story world
yeah you have to be a fictional
narrative and it's not what about social
media then like what if are you if
everyone in school has their phones and
social media and she's like come on dad
like gimme I want to I want to be I want
to fit in like everyone else in school
like to me there's a fantasy there in
social media it's like everyone's best
version of themselves oh yeah you need
some parameters you know it's contextual
it depends on how old they are who their
friends are how mentally developed they
are you know how what kind of social
media and and how they're interacting
with it yeah it's not gonna be the same
in 15 years as it is now yeah well I
mean everything I was hearing it's
basically um you need to wait until high
school basically even though that's
gonna that would make many kids insane
but thinking about like well seriously
for me like my worst years in school
were seventh through ninth grade yeah
like as far as like bullying I got that
spitballs I got my ass kicked I get all
that [ __ ] you know like I it was it was
everything and then to think about
adding social media on top of that like
when I already like was you know so
wound up and angry and like seeing all
you know all these people who all his
friends and groups it's like I would
have probably lost it you know and even
knowing for like girls at that age to
when that type of communication he's
even more weaponized in a way ya know
we're guys you know would fight in the
yard and girls would like you know
backstab in other ways with less
physical means you know it's way worse
for girls because of that and so I feel
like it's kind of one of those things
where you have to like hold off as long
as you can until the kid runs away and
steals a phone in the same predicament
to be in because it's like we didn't
have to deal with
our parents enough to deal with that
with us like I'm sure they had other
things to deal with yeah but this is
like an the social media the phones you
know being like what's HAP tin that's
that's a whole other element to throw
into the mix and I think it it it could
be very dangerous because at the end of
the day it's an addiction yeah you know
that eventually starts to change the way
you think yeah and the way you act right
so it's like I think every with
everything about it the other day comes
back to everything in balance you know
you'll have to have some order to it I
mean did you like well I guess for
example um did you guys communicate on
like internet forums when you're in
middle school you guys run into instant
messenger instant yeah well I I wasn't
really a forum junkie actually a little
bit yeah what's wrestling forums okay so
yeah well I mean I don't know if you
experienced it but like that was kind of
our thing our generations form of social
media at that age in the sense that we
had that anonymized level of
communication and you know I mean you
know you get up you make a post you make
a comment and if one person you know
comes after you it's like it's like oh
my god like oh you started questioning
your life like this is this person
smarter than me am i stupid are they
calling me out you know it's like you
mean even today I you know you make a
youtube video and you read one negative
comment that's like well written mm-hmm
and you're like okay I let hey everyone
hates me I let everyone down you know
it's just like imagine being in that
mind of a 13 or 14 year old and getting
that negative comment and like how much
poor much more poor poorly you can
handle that and I feel like that's the
best way you can really consider yeah
it's gonna be interesting cuz I I don't
know if it's more more reactionary to
that currently because we will be
considered we'll go down in history as
the amateurs of the information age you
know like I'm hearing all I'm just to
make an example um I just finished dan
Carlin's blueprint for Armageddon in
podcast which is incredible by the way
if you have a chance to listen to it
wow yeah definitely do that
but the point is when soldiers were
first introduced to the battlefields of
World War one that just got slaughtered
yeah and then people smartened up
they built trenches and then eventually
by the end of World War one
you'd open warfare which was basically
where things picked up in World War two
and we're gonna go down our generation
as that first those first people on the
battlefield in World War one getting
slaughtered by information because we're
the first generation that's had to deal
with it in mass and so I think
regardless of how we treat it we're
always gonna have people our history is
gonna look at us with that lens that's
interesting well it's kind of sounds
like what we were talking about with
Luke a little bit you know where it's
like we we're in this flux period here
where we don't fully understand the
consequences or repercussions of how
this will affect the day-to-day of
society that's kind of where yeah
exactly but like how do we handle that
and how we change it but I think we're
certainly in that in that turning point
although III mean I'm curious it's weird
cuz I don't feel like I'm leading
cavalry into machine-gun fire by
browsing the web so I saw him carry the
alarm and or maybe I mean we'll see
we'll see once people learn how to use
those machine maybe people haven't fully
figured out the machine guns yet or
maybe they have well it's that's the
world that's the world war one reference
here's a crazy here's a crazy idea
crazy thought so eventually you're gonna
be for installing technology in your
body or you're not gonna be for that
right I think it's gonna get to that
point yeah yeah definitely well have you
heard about Elon Musk's neural link I
have yeah yeah and I thought it was just
like him gonna be making like a fancy
like phone interface but then he's like
no no it's actually installing a
microchip in your brain it's like oh I
know that that was gonna be like like
when he was on Joe Rogan's podcast he
was talking about it oh and three months
four months it's coming out did it come
out you know I think he's who's gonna
announce it in three or four months it
was a tan
was it I think he did and it was like
not even a big announcement he basically
just but anyways yeah he it's basically
a way to get it's effectively AI and
Wikipedia in your brain at the same time
because it's gonna come to a point where
it's like you're gonna have to choose to
do that or to not and I think that's
gonna divide the world people people are
gonna be like nah I'm good and they're
just gonna be not as smart well it's it
I mean the interface has already exist
though today that's the thing it's like
right now we have like but like
physically installing something inside
it like rice but but think about it this
way and this is the way the same way
that it's been explained by by musk but
right now you have a phone you input
information into it it gives you
information back yeah right so there
that is the interface that's the link
that you currently have with cybernetics
I guess or technology which eventually
would become cybernetic right right and
all he's saying is like well what if you
didn't give the information with your
fingers you instead gave it with your
brain so it's like no big deal then like
what would you guys would you guys do
that it depends on how practical it is
yeah definitely if it's oh definitely do
it if it's if it's controllable right
you can turn it off there say like clear
logic link between it where it functions
in right now we're thinking about it and
like our minds eye you know look it in a
perfect way but it actually functions
how its intended to in the sense that it
doesn't take over your brain right it
doesn't like just go off you can you can
control it you can turn it off right all
these different things that are part of
it if it makes it easier for you to
interface with what will eventually be
the version of your phone I don't know
it just scares me man it's like you need
to be you need to have that to become a
member like a working member of society
like that's just the creepy well kills
trivia night that's for sure certainly
not gonna be able to play jeopardy on my
switch yeah I know
damn what actor elite actor was in ghost
ship and everyone's just like what well
there's already barriers to entry to
participating in society though Clint
you know and I think that about what
you're messing with
yeah but you tell like think about some
of you with you will you get that
implant just no my first instinct is no
then throw away that Adam Jensen jacket
all right hey I put it in that I put it
in the freakin storage closet um sir
it's already in the prop closet do you
is it because you realized you never
wore it I never asked for this you never
never ask that's why they say love is an
open door because love has no barrier to
entry and you can it's drafty it's
drafty in there it is drafty it comes
and goes sometimes it lifts in all the
heat and sometimes it lets out all the
heat you say you want say you you want a
job right you want a job a Jo B well
first of all what burgers first of all
just to flip burgers okay
like let's just break this down for a
second you need to be able to show up to
a place at the same time and leave at
the same time you need to be able to
collect form of payment you need to be
able to do the job so you need to be
able to speak the same language you need
to be able to show up and clean clothes
you need to be able to like communicate
with the other people around you we do
that already though I'm saying what I'm
saying is currently there's already huge
barriers to entry to even just getting
there like from a person you take a
person on the street you try to get him
there like we were at Big Bear today
well I mean that guy was talking to me
because I had that raft yeah we trying
to swim we were trying to rowboat and
Lake Hunter couldn't even speak English
to me he couldn't even communicate to me
because his mind was so just gone gone
or does he spoken differently maybe
speaking English but he wasn't speaking
in coherent maybe he was a cybernetic in
which and he clearly had like you know
obviously like some sort of mental
condition and he was homeless and he was
just standing outside and he was trying
to communicate with me I got you but his
way of communicating with me it was just
him like acknowledging the fact that I
had a raft and thinking it was funny the
same way that somebody who speaks like
Cantonese would communicate that to me
but even less directly you know that's
that was our level of communication even
though he was speaking English she's
never liked a universal language like
Google Translate and I'm just saying
like your bit you're like I don't think
it makes I don't think it changes a
whole lot to say like well now to
participate in society you need a piece
of technology because it first of all
that thing is gonna be super cheap
because they're gonna want to get one to
have it yeah right and then everyone
will be using it so you know it's I
don't know it's just not an easy
question to answer no it's not but I I
don't know I I want it to be expensive
as hell so I never have to watch and I
had in my brain oh that's how it's gonna
be if I want it to be super super
expensive how do you think it's gonna be
paid for probably all the the data and
like deep dark secrets that it gets to
look at what about it's gonna be paid
for through through ad money unless we
switch to universal healthcare some sort
never soul that mental should care yeah
cuz it's like it's it's free for
everyone you know what think about it
it's not I don't think Universal
Universal anything isn't free for
everyone by definition someone has to
pay for it still the problem is I mean
just I know here's the best way I think
I could explain a world where they're
cheap imagine you think you're let's say
you are watching a movie that's right
they still exist in 20 years no one's
making you anymore they exist since
you're watching this antique movie from
2009 stand in line watching John wick 3
with your son who's finally old enough
to watch it alright okay you've got your
cybernetic implant he watched an actor
on screen you're like oh who was that
actor and then the chip instantly is
going
oh that actor we're looking it up and
right before that word hits your mind
you get an advertisement for coca-cola
it's like it says by the way drink coke
anyways every word Oh peon and horribly
remove that the person you were looking
for is well I mean but it's what's the
difference you look it up on your phone
and I am DB pops up and the first thing
you see is an ad and they scroll down I
guess let me just let me just take
take this in a slightly different
direction I think the hardest thing
regarding I think maybe this is what
you're getting at Clint the hardest
thing would be the ability to like not
do something right say say you like have
a bad habit of buying things on Amazon
and you have this chip in your brain and
you think of something and I see that
water bottle and I go that's a cool
water bottle I want that and you already
have a bad habit of buying that thing
now chip no in the chip nose it's like
man that's where it starts to become a
very dangerous territory because anyone
who like pays attention to themselves
knows like hey I've got I've got this or
I've got that and there's certain things
that I just don't do because I know that
it's not good for me mmm right for some
people it's alcohol for some people it's
cigarettes for some people it's porn for
some people it's like accessories or
shopping you know and everyone has that
thing and I think if if the chip which
is this theoretical chip right that just
exists in everyone which is totally
terrific dystopian hypothetical but like
if it just does this thing and you can't
control it then like obviously that's
not good for anyone yeah but I don't
think this kind of stuff is ever
designed with bad intentions necessarily
I think they're designed in good with
good intentions and they're like are
aware that it's just usually you just
don't want to be in v1 of that chip you
want to be in v2 after they like iron
out their Google glass that would be one
of a our technology yeah but it's also
who's kind of useless it's basically
SmartWatch for your eyeball and so so is
useless it doesn't matter where you put
the SmartWatch but yeah I mean it's like
I feel like it's easy to joke about the
dystopian stuff but it's like I don't
think that's I don't think that's how
that that would really get realised
that's like it's kind of like no you're
solved for where like all the soldiers
have chips and then snake is the only
one without a chip and he's like I go
old school and then like you know they
start it gets all glitchy and then they
start getting controlled and he's like
I'm so glad I'm old school and then like
he gets infected and all in it gets all
crazy yeah yeah my brain just goes off I
like just come up
dumb stuff like that okay here here
here's just a just to piggyback on this
current topic do you think that extreme
opinions the reason why extreme opinions
are so popular today
is because with media being the way that
it is it's the it's the first time where
you can have such an a platform for such
an extreme opinion and get it out to as
many people
let me explain explain a little bit
further because that's not a very good
way that I explain that but let me start
over right now people can say anything
and previous to social media right you
didn't have this ability to for everyone
to be able to say something it was like
information was curated yeah you know
men people that were the people with the
extreme opinions would be like the
people standing in a park on a soapbox
saying this I didn't have a collective
it was just that yeah yeah and now and
so over time humans became conditioned
to basically if information is presented
to you whether it's like through media
or through in person uh-huh like if
somebody in-person me you and me and you
right here and I'm telling you my
opinion that opinion that I have is
gonna have more effect on you than if
you just like see it in a magazine
you know cuz I'm right here telling it
to you mm-hm and the same thing that if
you're watching the television program
and somebody that you recognize is
giving you an opinion you might be more
affected by that mm-hm
but now anyone can do that
young so you get these people with you
get the ability to like people are still
in the same sense in the old way
attached to opinion and so someone says
something extreme and you're like hey
that's extreme are you are you talking
about like how basically information had
to go through I guess a number of hands
before it was presented to the public
and now we're just talking about there's
there's no barrier to enter
and so and so that like democratization
of communication has kind of led to a
what is kind of like an ambiguity of
truth because usually if I'm like hey
I'm gonna go tell this to a million
people like I'll talk about it with a
few other people first and then we put
it out there that's I guess yeah that's
that's what I mean but that hierarchy
gets smaller and smaller until it's
basically one to two people right now
they can access so so like when it comes
to like fact-checking and ethics and
journalistic integrity yeah it's not a
those things just don't play and so yeah
that's that's that's what I just went a
long way and you cut to it more clearly
and and then basically what would you
have to do what do you think about it so
what I'm thinking what I'm saying is do
you think it's true that like if if you
just have a loud extreme opinion because
of the way that the environment is
currently it's taken as facts taken as
fact do you think that's actually
happening or do you think people just
like to talk about that because it's
something that seems like it could be an
explanation I think people like to be
right and justified in the things
they're saying and they're trying to
find people who agree with them and be
like yes yes I am validated in
everything I say yeah I don't want to be
wrong I don't want to be challenged okay
ever so now if people want to be right
they also want to feel like people like
people want to feel like they're a part
of something right yes so now take that
a step further and do you think that
given how much information in different
opinions and different ideas are out
there currently that there's this
there's this pulling on the fabric of
society effectively there's a pulling
apart and so people are gravitating
towards these different ideas to feel
like they're still part of like human
culture maybe well honestly I thought
the way I here's where I thought this
was going and I thought this was going
with the polarization of ideas and in
kind of that like incongruity but
between you know like it's it's the loss
of the gray area so to speak when it
comes to like discussion yeah but III I
thought that was going in the direction
of is that a cause because
life is better than ever and people need
to find conflict in more things yeah and
I think I'm waiting there out the long
way to the same surface because you know
think if you think about sports teams
two teams basically you know it's a
metaphor for combat you know just in a
different way it's a different set of
rules different constraints but it's
basically it you know it's no different
than arena battles etc but because of
you know improvement of quality of life
etc people's innate competitive and
competitive combative instincts create
or or or I guess emphasize and
exaggerate things that are not large
conflicts but they turn them into big
ones because they lack that conflict in
their life maybe yeah I I think that
people are generally stressed and
anxious especially today like everyone's
running around trying to do a million
things trying to you know trying to feel
important be important have their voice
heard they need someone else to tell
them that they're doing a good job they
need someone else to validate their
existence and like that's that would be
very stressful yeah so maybe starting
arguments or trying to you know it's
built up energy going in a certain
direction possibly I know I'm not saying
like I know but like yeah maybe that's
the thing I think working out is another
way to get rid of that that energy um I
don't know
yeah I I don't know I think like what
we're pretty sedentary yeah right
because I think there's a lot of
theories surrounding it because I think
I think right now I think the the one
objective fact statement truth that you
can kind of point towards is that right
now people are very can be very loud
people can have very loud voices on
paper you can project it out and I would
argue that in the world of opinions and
content and news there's more voices
than ever and so you know are we looking
at that is maybe the actual cause here
just there's more content therefore
there's more conflict because there's
more opinion out there you know and it's
just if everything has scaled up or is
there something that's more targeted
happening here you know it's is is the
content shifting in a in a certain
direction that we're able to kind of
pick up on here or maybe
maybe it's just kind of all in your head
two ends is that does that type of
content where there are two people on
polar ends and polar opposites going at
it is that type of content I guess more
attractive as a listener or viewer so
it's like it's it's like I don't know
wet right now if it's an effect or like
a symptom or something that's or ate a
misconception a Mis misperception in a
weird way and something I think about
very frequently I don't know well um I
think drama is interesting I think
that's why like I've never seen an
episode of Kardashians but that's a
reality show right yeah and the whole
like dramatic reality show kind of
craziness going on with YouTube people
call them people out drama here and
there like that's interesting tabloids
People magazine all that stuff like
who's got the beef on you know it's like
and then people gravitate towards that
stuff yeah and like the media probably
knows this they probably got they do
what can I tell you guys one of the
juiciest pieces of political news that
I've ever heard yeah Nancy Pelosi the
newly appointed Speaker of the House
mm-hmm basically disinvited Trump from
delivering the State of the Union yeah
she did that isn't that insane
that's pretty crazy isn't that pretty
like basically just saying hey don't
don't come here don't talk to us we
don't want to give you a platform you
know like I think that's some of the
juiciest juiciest drama and it would not
be created without this like absolute
polarization well she's saying that
because the government's shut down well
she is she's saying don't do it while
the government's shut down that's what
she was saying I know I'm saying I'm
still I'm still it's kind of its kind of
like a pretty big fu oh yeah well yeah I
like dividing the houses like they're
dividing the the branches of government
like that exactly yeah no that's no good
I mean that's that's in another way
that's what I was getting at to like
this
comes from all these different places
now and so do you think that that's
having a negative effect in a way
because it's tearing people it's tearing
the fabric of society apart you know
like people used to have information
from it for better or for worse right
because the naysayer will always say
well like if everyone everyone back in
the day 200 hundred years ago whatever
if everyone came from the this
judeo-christian background with like X Y
& Z and you gotten your news from all
the same places and you kind of did all
the same things as everyone else which
marginalized other people that weren't
that which I understand and there's
value to not just having one opinion but
also at the same time I also think in
opening the floodgates to literally
everyone with an opinion about anything
that is also creating this sort of like
modern Babel situation where everyone is
saying different things and that's
actually tearing down hmm any fabric of
a communication and ground
yeah common ground I mean amongst people
I guess so I means more I feel like it's
partially you can add you could
attribute the death of like monoculture
to it
obviously when you we we talk about you
know you have music industries film
industry entertainment for that matter
like basically mass communication you
know obviously that's for entertainment
purposes but happened to the music
industry you know you have the death of
monoculture there's no like I guess
there's still some quite large bands and
rappers out there but I would say most
people musical tastes are far more
diverse and that's like the most
monoculture musician out there like
great great yeah yeah but that's that's
music though when it comes to like
morals and beliefs that just gets
confusing because I the way I feel I
feel confused like again I was raised
Christian I was raised to believe you
know that that God exists that Jesus
exists that Jesus was raised from the
dead three days after they crucified him
he came back and he died for everyone to
give everyone a chance you know be
saying Christ in Christian class yeah
and that was 20 years of my life that
was every Sunday go to church and you
know just learn about learn about Jesus
learn about God and
and honestly like since coming out
moving away from that physically moving
across the United States
yeah to a different place it's like I
don't have to listen to my parents
anymore I don't I don't I do what I want
I do exactly what I want exactly so I
stopped going to church and I was like
well why am I going to church am I going
to church my parents my going to church
for me and I realized like I'm going to
church my parents I can't I shouldn't be
doing that I need to find my own path I
need to find my own way right so I
stopped going to church and I just start
questioning things like what how and why
and what dude I can't even believe what
the news is telling me they there
there's a spin on everything there's a
bias on everything and everyone has
their secret reason as to why I'm
telling you this information and we want
you to feel this way like right I don't
think it's like you know 1984 but like
there's some creepy stuff there's some
creepy stuff in there currently like in
the news right now and my dad watches
news 24/7 and it's like dude that stuff
is so dark and depressing and I don't
watch news at all I do not I would
rather like not just have that I don't
want to have that right I don't want to
have that and I know yes it might be
stupid people might call me out on that
but that's just the way I choose to live
my life it's hard to know what is is the
truth the truth right and if it's hard
to believe what the news is telling me
how am I supposed to believe what this
book says you know that was written for
so long ago and then there's all these
other religions to that that claim that
they aren't they're the right ones right
so I'm just confused
generally and then when it's coming to
politics in the news it's just confusion
I said I just see people fighting that's
all I see Republicans Democrats I hate
this side I hate that side it's like why
do you even call it like why isn't it
just like one group of people and like
they have different points about some
stuff and like I think just calling them
to different things sets it up so that
they're just I hate that side and I'm
not going to vote for that side because
they're called Republicans and then I'm
not gonna vote for so because they're
Democrats uh it's like
dang dude ah it's just confusing man
it's confusing and I kind of like right
now I've kind of just like right it's a
lot dude it's a lot and I know I have to
dig it I know how to say you you or not
you're no longer unemployed on your
opinion you're out of the workforce what
was it's an economic reference I'm sorry
in economics yeah in economics is this
idea that people that are unemployed are
still in the workforce but they can't
find a job and when people leave the
workforce because they eventually give
up on finding a job they are no longer
considered unemployed they're considered
out of the workforce so when they say
that unemployment rate is four percent
right that those that's four percent of
people that are in the workforce still
looking for a job it doesn't consider
all the people that are known that have
given up have you no longer of trying
I'm curious are you familiar of any
instances where the UH the the
unemployment rate goes down due to
people leaving the workforce so it looks
like yeah they could be happening right
now actually you think so yeah well
right now we're at this economically so
here's here's a here's a rebuttal to
what I would say what you were saying
and just or maybe you know another
opinion on it and then also decide that
what Sam just asked me economic news is
actually very enlightening because they
can't lie it's like sports in a way did
somebody win or lose mm-hm and so
there's all these parameters right but
in general the reason why I watch more
economic news than any other form of
news and why I read more economic news
than any other form of news is because
there's winners and losers and in
politics that's not always true it's
usually not true at all and so to tie
into what's going on currently Sam where
we're at this point where no one quite
knows if we're in a recession or not we
might be we might not be everyone no one
seems to know we just went through this
huge ten year up cycle and now we're
kind of just floating around and like
there's different parameters and like
all the opinions on TV have different
opinions about what what's gonna happen
and the unemployment rate currently is
like at one of its lowest like if the
queue for job numbers came in
recently and they were way people had
more jobs than anyone thought they were
gonna have and so it immediately made me
think like a are more people leaving the
workforce cuz I can't find work and with
more people being contractors than ever
before like does that mean people are
employing themselves well before
I mean I'm that's actually something
really interesting because right now we
live in a time where you don't like you
don't need it up w2 salary ya to get by
and there's so many many ways YouTube
being one goober yeah
right one like like you there are so
many things that just are not in that
traditional realm of what you would
consider employment you know if you over
it every day like what what how like how
much ubering do you have to do to be
considered an employee or employed so to
speak they don't I don't I could be
wrong about this but I don't believe
they employ you well what I'm getting at
is that for it to count when it comes to
a job number or census like that well
what would happen is you'd say it you're
self-employed and then the government
would look at that number and go great
this guy's got a job that makes sense
you employed himself
that's a job yeah we'd be sole
proprietors yeah so that's when they
would sales taxes and so even though
there's like less pop probably there's
probably less w-2 jobs out there but
because there's more people doing that I
think they're thinking that we're happy
pallab more jobs than ever before when I
don't think that's necessary yeah I
think it's people yeah more people are
self-employed but not quite getting by
on the same way that they would have
before in a more tradition employees
itself differently by and large than the
generation before it but I don't know
how much the generation before us really
realizes that and so since they're the
ones who are doing most of the numbers
yeah currently I don't know if they're I
think there's I think there's a
disconnect there but we'll find out you
know we'll find out in the next two
years mm-hmm we're about to begin
Clint's story about his harrowing and
near-fatal experience on a film
set and I would definitely say listener
discretion is advised because we are
about to talk about near fatal injuries
there is a little bit of blood there
might be a little bit of gore and it
might not be best for those of you who
are squeamish to those types of things
that being said it's definitely a very
profound and life-changing story if you
are into that so here it is this is
whenever we change topics this is what
we is what we use Clint um couple years
ago you were up in Los Angeles Crest
National Forest
mm-hmm and it was an incident or a man
on a motorcycle injured it got severely
injured I gave you a call yeah a day
after it happened yeah I was worried
already worried I did explain a little
bit about what happened there and how it
affected your life um so new camera came
out yeah the company contacted me it was
like hey got a new camera you want to
make something cool for it we'll give me
the camera I was like yeah of course so
I decided to do some sort of some cool
like motorcycle shots up in on the two
Angeles Crest Highway yeah no big deal
right just call up some of my friends
who enjoy riding motorcycles and I got
two people one of them was a good friend
of mine the other was a friend or an
acquaintance of an acquaintance I didn't
know the guy yeah so we met in Pasadena
and we decided hey guys I just wanna get
some cool shots of you guys riding
around we'll treat it like I'll cut it
together like it's a chase sequence you
know but I'm just gonna get really cool
of close shots we have a pickup truck
I'll be in the back of the pickup truck
filming with this sweet new stabilizer
or camera thing yeah you guys get as
close as close as you can safely and I
will film you and I'll let
no I'll push my hand back we need you to
go back I'll pull you forward and we'll
only max out at this speed we're not
gonna go fifty we're gonna go 25 or
something that's dangerous dude that's
super dangerous um that alone man so we
go up there and I film one of the
writers goes well before we before we
film I say hey if I ask you guys to do
anything that you don't feel comfortable
doing tell me no and we won't do it yeah
it was just verbal there was no written
thing it's not there's no there's no
insurance in production but it's just
like I'm just up there to get cool shots
everyone was there voluntarily exactly
yeah so I shoot I shoot the first writer
all good we pull over we talked about
plans for the second writer he hasn't
got he hasn't been filmed yet and we're
setting up a shot where it'd be as if I
mean the shot was basically this where
I'm in the pickup truck we're going like
thirty right and then from out of frame
the motorcycle pulls him from the side
and is going the same speed as the truck
mm-hmm so we found a big ol side turn
off on the road and we had that rider
positioned at the top of that turnoff we
were gonna come around the bend
pass him as soon well as soon as he sees
us he he picks up speed we pass him he
pulls behind us or like an on-ramp like
an honor on a road and there's like a
on-ramp that then merges in with it yeah
and the cameras looking backwards he's
facing the camera and he just pulls up
to the same speed as us
okay that's what we talked about and so
we execute the shot he's at the top of
the the turnoff we come around pass him
at like 30 and we just he's not moving
right okay
that shots biffed but he slowly starts
to pickup truck is still going he's a
good like three hundred feet behind us
he pulls out on the road and starts
picking up and by the time he gets
halfway to our car I'm in the back of
this pickup truck filming him getting
closer so I got 150 meters away at this
point
yeah the the truck driver slams on the
brakes and I'll get into why he did that
in a second so he slams on the brakes
and at this point the motorcycle is
still picking up speed towards us and he
receives you're stopped by now we're not
stopped no it happened very fast
we're not stopped he's picking up speed
he's picking up speed and I had footage
of it so I know that six seconds passed
between the brakes and the collision
where he hit the back of the pickup
truck and he did a double front flip
over the pickup truck over my head and
landed face first onto the pavement and
slid a good like 10 to 15 feet and I was
just started screaming like oh my god oh
my god oh my god screaming yeah and at
this point I had I was at the back the
pickup truck I'd slid to like the window
part and punk stand up I run over to him
and he's making this horrible sound like
trying to breathe and I don't touch him
we like I'm like pacing trying to figure
out what to do this guy might be dead I
don't know we're trying to call 9-1-1
but there's no service so the other the
other motorcyclist flies down the
mountain to get service at this point
Alex de Vecchio shows up randomly
randomly and he's like what's going on
I
explain it he wasn't invited to the
shooting no he was just there dude he
just pulled up and then he zipped down
the mountain on a motorcycle he was on
his motorcycle he was cruising around
he's up Stan the mountain and at this
point like dude the guy like there's
blood coming out of his mouth and he's
making this horrible like sound like
trying to breathe I'm like Jacob Jacob
dude
dude you're gonna be okay man Stu hang
in there hang in there it's gonna be
chill so I was like trying to calm
myself down you know him at the same
time of course no reaction from him he's
just in his in his world
um maybe five minutes later an ambulance
pulls up and Alex caught the ambulance
or he caught he caught a tow truck who
called amulets came up and they started
cutting his pants off cutting his shirt
off and like they left his helmet on and
you know eventually I heard the
helicopters come in and and they told us
they got they got all the info from us
sent us sent us back we went to the
hospital in Pasadena that he was gonna
be at so we're waiting at the hospital
we don't know if he's dead we don't know
if he is a vegetable we don't know
anything all we know it was like we need
to wait here at the at the ER before you
know her for him to get there and figure
out what's going on so dude I'm freaking
out I'm freaking out at this point I
don't know what to do I can't call
myself down and an hour later maybe two
hours later of waiting there we get news
that his brain has swelled and is
pressing against the skull and he has
all of these blood clots in his brain
and like they have to saw his skull open
to like let the brain breathe or else
he's gonna die yeah and I was like - no
man they didn't know if he's gonna make
it or not so the next day I call you I'm
like Jake here's the situation I'm
prepared to go to jail for
know how long because I set up the shot
dude I set up the shot it was my like I
felt like I was to blame for this whole
thing so I called you I was like dude
what like in my am I to blame for this
yeah do I can I like can am I gonna lose
all my money
am I gonna loot am I gonna be screwed
for my life like and and saying it now
is kind of like selfish like dude is the
guy gonna live yeah
but I'm also thinking like am I gonna be
in jail for how long and like am I can
she have to pay him for the rest of my
life so base thought based on what you
told me I kind of got a peace of mind a
little bit yeah um ended up visiting him
two weeks later and he was like swelled
up like a balloon I had to meet his
whole family he wasn't conscious like I
like went to go hold his hand and he
just was like like holding my hair I was
like dude like are you pissed at me or
like he he was out he was out of it I
didn't know what to think and um
dude meeting his family was the worst it
was so bad it was the worst situation so
you know the cops got involved and they
got the footage and they were like
reviewing it and and all this the truck
driver Simon on the brake because he
thought we were gonna pull over to meet
the other riders like no that was never
discussed um you know and it ended up I
didn't talk to him for a year the the
writer who got who's in the hospital I
didn't talk to her for a year I found
out he forgot who his cousins were he
forgot he was like number one top of
class Navy eronel Air Force forgot all
the stuff you learned he was like
recommended by Obama to be at the top
whatever that got cut off couldn't be a
part of anything like that anymore he
was like number one engineer
mathematician guy shut down like it'd be
like Ren times
friggin five just forgetting everything
put on like 50 60 pounds I was like dude
this guy's life is freakin done and I
would check his facebook every so often
and he'd be like I'm so
I'm so pissed and like I'd be like oh
dude and I so I called him a year later
and I was like after he called me he
called me I couldn't answer I I just
couldn't I couldn't a couple weeks
passed by he calls me I pick up and we
talked for like two hours and basically
he tells me all the things I'm telling
you about his his state and how he had
these crazy dreams and like his dream
how he has crazy dreams man and and and
and basically he told me like dude it's
not your fault truck driver
hit the brakes you were just filming it
and like that kind of gave me some
closure to thought all the things I was
feeling about it right and to see him
posting on Facebook like better than
ever now and like how he his life is
changed for the better because of his
mindset and his approach to everything
and how like nothing's gonna stop him
they told him he'd never walk again but
he's running and like all this I'm like
dude that was a close one
that was a freaking close one dude when
did his mindset change when he contacted
you um it was I mean it was around the
time it wasn't like a clear like
yesterday I was this and today I'm that
yeah it was it definitely over time
that's the link to this to this day is
still he's still like coping with it and
it was like three years ago in October
yeah uh yeah a lot of feelings that's
what does that teach you about about
life what did that teach you about
yourself well safety number one
communication let's not do anything
unless we're all on the same page about
it yeah especially if it's dangerous
yeah also let maybe let's not do it
unless we're working with stunt guys you
know yeah who are down for that kind of
stuff yeah those are those are those are
a couple things after hearing it the
first thing I feel and think is how you
should not take for granted
all the things that go right in your
life even even if they're small whether
you're on like like us on a film set and
we do something where a guy rolls down a
hill and thankfully no one rolls onto a
rock or whatever or you drop a knife
while cleaning it it doesn't stab you in
the foot or whatever but like it's just
that you definitely start taking that's
kind of stuff for granted like all the
near misses that you have or even the
things that you do that are a little
caught you know reckless whether they're
big or small and when you end up for the
better you're like oh yeah no big deal
it always happens but even in this
situation which could have been easily
prevented there like even listening to
it it's like there's more multiple
points where you think oh someone will
do something right or someone won't do
something wrong or you know because that
keeps happening but then everything
doesn't go the direction you think it
will and it's easy to take that for
granted for sure it also made me realize
like why my what am i doing dude making
films I'm making short films on the
Internet yeah and this dude almost lost
his life and and he's a vegetable for a
year and he can't remember all the stuff
he devote his entire life to is it worth
it no and so that that yeah that's just
like dude not worth not worth no not at
all
yeah I think well this ties into
something we talked about right before
we started the cast but I think the well
one of the main one of the only solace
is in a situation like that is who's
around you in a time like that you know
like this guy hopefully the people
around him are one of the reasons why he
was able to to change
his direction a little bit and hopefully
still to this day but uh yeah that's
funny it's funny when you bring it when
you
well first we should definitely put like
a little listener discretion thing on
the front of this thing here because
that's a very it's a graphic story but
it's funny it's actually there's
something funny there's something
there's lightness that comes with the
darkness because you're like hey let's
talk about your motorcycle story and I'm
like this one's gonna be a doozy
it's probably gonna talk about when
Spencer first got his motorcycle license
over powered motorcycle he'd never
ridden and it was too too strong and
then slips on some sand and it lands on
his ankle and everyone had a great time
except for Spencer the best part is they
got worse and everyone's got better the
pictures dude the picture is like you
can see it's like yeah motorcycles very
dangerous I think I think we should know
that but that's established it's the
pictures yeah so I I heard I heard about
the story like what happened it's
basically a whole big picture here uh
about a few years back we did some
harley-davidson classes got our our
licenses and it kind of kind of started
getting passed around and we ended up
getting a contact who works at
harley-davidson who basically it was uh
basically sending out you know loaner
bikes he's the wrong guy he's the market
yeah yeah so so he we got loaner bikes
for anyone who had a motorcycle license
and basically a big old motorcycle trip
got organized with everyone on these
loaner motorcycles yeah the Google kids
kids and Spencer yeah Spencer Skoglund
ur are our boy next door
yeah he biffed it crushed his ankle or
whatever I'm with the bike and was in a
cast for a few much detail this a little
bit further oh wait wait wait I want to
hear this thing about the photos so I
hear the story and like dude what what
what happened and I'm like freaking out
and then you're like yeah it was like on
Mulholland or something we're like
there's that curve there's an infamous
there's an infamous turn on Mulholland
called the snake because it's so windy
and all the street bikers go up there
every weekend to go around him to go on
the snake it's an advanced like it's
erased yeah but you can go slow and it's
fine yeah and it's communal and
everyone's kind of there and people are
taking pictures and it's like it's kind
of a spot where all bikers in SoCal go
and they and everyone kind of like shows
off a little bit on the snake and the
photographers yeah on the side there's
like amateur motorcycle photographers
like then yeah okay and so a
professional for that matter so no no so
we went we went up the PCH and we
thought we'll just go up the hill and
we'll come back down Mulholland freeway
and we'll go through the snake we'll
real slow were you there Clint I was not
I was not actually on the ride oh no I
was not on the right I was hearing this
like the next we yeah and then and then
Spencer was on this he was on a twelve
hundred Sportster he'd never been on one
before and he was in the back and he was
following his brother who was a had his
own bike who is an experienced rider or
more experienced anyway and so we we all
we're spread out
single-file right we're going super slow
where no one's pushing it we're going
slow we're on like big old bikes no none
of us have ridden together before it
wasn't like we just went up there and we
were busting lying that's what I'm
imagining
that's not what happened at all we were
all being super chill except Spencer was
having trouble keeping up with his
brother and so we he went down the hill
and I don't know you know he hasn't told
me this directly but I think he was
trying to keep up a little bit okay
rather than just riding his own pace and
we said to everyone before we're like
we're going on the snake it's windy it's
dangerous just go slow right at your own
pace and enjoy it
right just go as slow as you need to go
that was the rule before we left right
don't try to keep up with other people
and there's a stopping point called the
rocks tour when you get down the snake
and we were all gonna stop there and we
all get down there and then all the
sudden the last four guys don't show up
like what happened and so dare me
the guy who hooked us up with that
licenses rides back up there and he
comes back down and he's like Spencer
broke his ankles
like what what happened he was going
around and turned too fast and he slid
into the dirt and he slowed the bike
almost entirely down so the turns like
this he goes ah right and there's like a
rock face here there's like a sandstone
wall here and there's a cliff on the
other side but he's turning in so he's
like turning into the rock he goes a
little too far
slides into the dirt the bike comes to a
stop and like right as it comes to a
stop you know that point where it's
supposed to like not fall he just a
little too far it just went out in time
and snapped in so afters ankle so I hear
the story and and you tell me about the
website there's a website where people
post pictures of people coming on the
bend and there's like freaking ZZ Top
coming around the corner a friggin
freakin Speed Racer on his speed bikes
come around
you got you got the guy on the fricking
the ha the hog they go hog with the
speakers on the side boom yeah turn
around and there's sparks his exhaust
pipe is scraping on the there's three
pictures every one second picture he's
he's got rocks shooting out the back of
higher because he goes too far off the
side of the road and a third picture
he's crossed over the yellow line into
the other pipes and flying into oncoming
traffic
[Laughter]
there's no actual documented footage of
me crash and that was all there was I'm
so sad that we'll never be able to find
those photos oh wait can we I remember
trying to look I remember hearing
something like this but I couldn't find
it it'd be deep in the arc this is a
perfect example of what you were just
saying Sam it went the right way this
time
it went the right way like we very
easily could have been going on of the
other side sorry I just had to bring
that up just to like like there's no I
mean that last story is tragic man and
it's like really messed up and I feel
terrible that you had to go through it
but I'm also I guess relieved and you
know I guess proud that you were able to
go through and that guy was able to go
through it and survive and regain
control of his life after such like a
catastrophic thing and you know talking
about Spencer no I wish I wish well
there's someone there online there
online somewhere
oh my god Oh anyways so that's the only
way we can get out of that boys yeah I
think that that wraps it up I think
that's the end of the corridors the
corridor crew cast is what we're calling
them now what we learned is don't take
life for granted and get out there get
out there out there don't be shy don't
be afraid of the chip be skeptical of
this don't be peer pressure didn't get
into a cybernetic implant don't be
Marine cord into getting a cybernetic
slip the chip in don't worry about that
that's a don't worry about that yeah
yeah and it's not yeah we also learned
it's normal for a young boy do you want
to join the Marines very normal I mean
anyone who's Buffay any boy who's played
army I think yeah you hear about the
army and you're like oh the Army's cool
and then some
like have you heard of the Marines yeah
yeah like yeah there's like they get
more badass yeah how is that possible
yeah all right well it's been good
talking guys yeah till next time signing
off thank you everybody for listening to
the corridor cast if you enjoyed this
episode don't forget to subscribe on
youtube or on Apple podcast or Google
podcast doesn't matter and if you really
especially liked it consider checking
out our patreon corridor digital or hop
on over to our merch store at corridor
digital dot store because every shirt
you buy runs great episodes like this
and keeps those podcasts coming thanks
again for listening and we'll see you
next time